is in Chicago
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Amelia
hello thank you for having me
sure what's up so I had a question about
we were to draw some boundaries with my
parents who with money who are helping
us out a little bit as we've just had a
baby and things just tend to be a little
hairy with them and I'm moving with how
to keep it fair to them and also without
you know messing up our progress okay so
what is it they're trying to give you
money or they need money what are you
saying
so I'm sorry um so we are moving home to
pay off our debt so my long-term we're
moving in with our parents they are
doing some renovations on their basement
so that we can live there for a few
months and save some money
and from there kind of decide where
we're going to go and we have we have an
agreed-upon rent rate and we actually
gave them rent in advance to help pay
for some of those renovations because I
knew they wouldn't have the money up
front and it just kind of already
started happening where they know I have
some savings and they're starting to you
know asking me for money to borrow and
while I do trust that they'll give it
back I just I find I'm just not sure how
fair it is of me to say I'm not
comfortable you know having this this
borrower lender relationship when
they're also helping me out and I don't
know what's fair to them and fair to me
okay so how much do you have in savings
right now I have eleven hundred dollars
and then I also have about two hundred
and twenty-eight dollars just for
expenses for the baby if something comes
out like only old are you I'm 29 I'll be
30 in about a month how old are they
they're my mom is 60 she's 60 years old
and she needs $1,100 oh no she doesn't
need $1,100 that's how much I have in
savings thing well 200 it's about 300
why does she need a couple of hundred
dollars and she's 60 years old she's
that broke they're not they're not good
with money into the basement then how
much money did you give them for that oh
it was basically rent for two months so
they have a very reasonable rent for us
it's $400 a month we gave them $800 is
what the renovations cost just for the
flooring yeah just to kind of get it so
we could could live there because it was
a it's been finished previously but we
ripped up the carpet and then it was
just a cement floor so they just put in
some vinyl flooring for us and some
paint and stuff my mom is also helping
with child care one day a week well mom
were too broke to loan money or any
money I love it you're broke you have
eleven hundred dollars that's not me
you're broke yeah and so we don't have
any money alone I've got a baby and
we're trying to get out of debt that's
why we're moving homes cuz we're broke
right right and if she can't accept that
you don't need to be moving in there
matter of fact you really don't need to
be moving in there because if because
this relationship has got its got
toxicity written all over it I made that
I got to tell you I'm 58 years old the
chances of me asking my 29 year old for
200 bucks is zero I think it killed him
I think you think it really hurt him to
have to ask me yeah well I mean I just
wouldn't have I'd have gone and eat dirt
in the backyard for I did I mean it's
not I'm not gonna ask my kids who have
brand-new babies and are broke for money
that's just pitiful and so yeah so I
mean it's just I did so what that tells
me is is that your mom and dad either in
a bad position and B this is not going
to go away with one conversation
I mean you really think this is going to
go away when you just have a magic
sentence or two to give her new probably
not nope not gonna go away you're gonna
have problems as long as you are
receiving anything from her she is going
to expect you to reciprocate as long as
you're receiving day care from her and
housing from her she's gonna expect
money from you because she does she's
not in a position to simply give she
feels like that there everything has to
be received and so you're paying her
rent for two months you've already paid
her rent for two months I guess you're
gonna try to go through with this but I
gotta tell you it's gonna be very very
difficult to go through and come out the
other side with a quality relationship
intact you're just going to be very kind
and very gentle and very firm and just
go mom we want to be money okay we gonna
live in under dollars you know I'll get
$1,100 but that's not any money when you
have a baby and we're trying to get out
of debt that's where we're moving in
here and if I had uh-huh if I had a 11
million dollars I'd give you 200 but I
don't have to let me know I got $1,100
we're as broke as you are and so we're
not in a position to give you money I'm
sorry and you know we just can't I'm
sorry and she's gonna pout and stomp her
little foot and get red in the face
because she feels entitled am I missing
something I mean a little less bratty
about it but yeah that's about it yeah
well maybe it'll be passive-aggressive
instead of just aggressive aggressive
yeah maybe
okay but I mean she's I it's just the
kind of a person that's 60 years old
nest a 29 year old kid for 200 bucks is
not the kind of person that's gonna take
a know easily so you need to expect some
reaction when you give the note right
and and by the way given or $200 is not
going to not going to make her not have
the reaction the next time she asks for
it which will be in two weeks right so
it's just that's the problem I mean it's
the same thing a guy comes in
here the day and he's like Dave God told
me that you were gonna give me a van and
I said no he didn't know and she said
well he said well what do you mean
aren't you a Christian I said yeah I'm a
Christian I talked to God every morning
and if God told you that he was going to
give that I was going to give you a van
there'd be one sitting out there with
car keys in it ready for you but he
didn't tell me
and so since he didn't tell me you're
making this up because you just think
well you're not a real Christian he gets
mad too stomps out why cuz I gave him a
boundary that is a crazy but couldn't
accept right right and so that's in a
dramatic example you're not going to
face something that crazy obviously but
anytime you tell people know that feel
entitled you generally get a negative
reaction generally anger and so that's
what you're facing I'm afraid I'm sorry
I wish I could give you better news but
I don't think this is gonna get better I
wish I could give you a magic phrase but
I just say mom as gently as I can I love
you and I'd help you if I can but I
can't I got a brand-new baby we're
living in your basement because we're
broke did you notice that and we're
trying to get out of debt we got eleven
hundred dollars to our name I'm like I'm
not gonna deplete that with a baby
sitting here my job as the mommy is to
take care of this baby you taught me
that sorta and you know that's what we
got to deal with here so I that's the
only way you can talk to her about it
good luck with it but I have very few
good results of drawing boundaries for
boundary-less people they generally
don't react well to it you can pretty
much expect that